[Music]
welcome to Rochester New York the home
of codex Eastman situated on Lake
Ontario and creator of the finest
delicacy in all the land that my friends
is the garbage plate and let me tell you
it is glorious my name is Alex Tahoe my
grandfather invented the original
garbage plate called hops and potatoes
and my father perfected the real garbage
plate at this point you're probably
wondering what this so-called garbage
plate is I'll tell you what garbage
plate is let me handle this
garbage plate starts with your choice of
sides from home fries french fries
macaroni salad or beans and you pick
your feet
hot dogs hamburgers cheeseburgers
whatever's on the menu then you add your
toppings from mustard onions and hot
sauce ketchup and red hot is optional
then I had two pieces of Italian bread
and butter and you're all set to go over
the years we've had a lot of different
kind of garbage plates we actually had
our sardine plate years ago I don't see
you can get much crazier than sardines
[Music]
the best part of this business is of
course the customers without them would
be nothing
the place was established to give people
a lot of food in a reasonable price for
years people have come in here hungry
and didn't have any money
my father always fed them that's really
sweet Alex but let's get back to the
garbage because I'm really wondering how
many calories are in a plate I really
don't know some people have said 3,000 I
don't think it's that high but yes
they'd have to be a nutritionist to tell
you but I will say this is the only
equation you get a garbage plate and the
other plate in Rochester is a copycat we
trademarked it so now it's world-famous
trademarking garbage
genius so this is a story about butter
that you never knew you always wanted
hopefully we begin before the appetizers
arrive when the bread comes with the
butter but this butter this is the star
of the meal it can be found in the town
in France called st. Mello from a family
hug buddy a jean-yves is the main butter
guy these days look and all these
different kinds of butter the third
generation in a line of butter making
royalty nobility come home palatable yes
hello Olivier possibly more important
they are maybe not in Kuna Yala butter
and the butter here is different the
butter we are going to talk about
finally right is full of seaweed and
used by some of the best chefs in the
world
ser Boros Ali was a little more like
waked me the jewels related mail general
kizhe the Rajas she no little pal given
the hosts of Lamia Weiser does it only
come here until double time but then
something happened something big there a
little bit for Joel Robuchon was a
French chef in 1989 he was named chef of
the century he has 32 Michelin stars
more than a dozen restaurants around the
world 19 cookbooks
he ran a syndicated television show in
France and perhaps at the end of the day
he will be best remembered for his
mashed potatoes I beseech you know same
old FA said well and approval chef de
cuisine Oh mother
satellizer have a salmon silicosis
evolved in power mode Keaton Taylor so
important whisky visibly adonia excel
he'll lashes derive a hammam or libel -
se a Vida Lisa Rivera table
- no burrs unfasten a allamanda palette
my limited data la familia organ chef
hace the homemade leadership tablet a la
coaches feel whole new door in
fabrication built artisanal I feel like
the one question everyone who is still
watching this video wants to know is
what it tastes like
what does seaweed butter taste like Rosa
you see angora so you dare you said a
comedy duo Zalgiris divita families you
motion liberals in promenade uber drove
away creepy deliberate nullificator boo
boo in Burma antler the Contra
university film blue to shake Nima
canary on the process welkerville or me
nothin
[Music]
this is pizza
now before you pizza purists destroy us
in the comments please open your mind
and let me explain this is zanzibar
pizza many people in the only no Italian
pizza we call is about pizza because of
the materials because other materials is
only from asthma like eternally Pisa but
it is same same but different meet
Muhammad he is the best pizza maker in
Zanzibar and is pretty well known around
his hometown I'm famous because I'm
making a pesto pizza also because I've a
good smile and thought oh I didn't know
I was with the celebrity I'm working
with pizza Master Chef master pizza
anyway Mohammed is a fixture at the for
Adani Garden night market making pizza
both sweet and savory for over 10 years
they make a different duty type of Pisa
like the Pentium or more than 20 every
morning Muhammed goes to the local
market for the very best and fresh
ingredients in order to make his
one-of-a-kind homemade Zanzibar pizza
pies after that I take in my chopped
chopped vegetable a karate Pony only
green pepper fresh tomato and then I mix
the center then I put the MRIs cheese
and the egg then I take the beef with a
my spiced masala and then I mix together
and then I close for all sides I take it
then I put for the BBQ the dough
presence of our pizza is actually
chapati
unleavened bread which is also made by
hand I take my flour and the author I
mix only flour in Georgia after that
I've got the ball big and small
I make a small chapati because the is
like a supporter and helped me to carry
Pisa to put to the power - mmm that
sounds good
Kosmic is like the best in the world
I feel happy because of the yum yum
TomTom and that my friends is pizza
zanzibar pizza
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the song
goal here in big noir Utah my name is
Missy Stewart and today we're going to
make our famous pickle pi pika PI is a
dessert it's not the sweetest pie we
have but it is the most original took a
lot of imagination I think to invent a
dessert pie with a pickle Inlet the
original owner found the recipe in a
magazine she didn't like the recipe at
all so she changed it around and now the
pickle pie is the very best jazz far as
I know we are the only place that makes
the pickle pie in pickle pie you will
find sugar butter milk eggs lemon
extract cornstarch cinnamon nutmeg and
of course the pickles so we've got this
all mixed in really nice and smooth so
now we're gonna pour it into our unbaked
pie shell to put in the oven scrape the
edges so you get all the flavor and this
one right here is one that we baked this
morning Wow pickle pie this is delicious
a little tiny bit of cream on it just
gives it that a little bit of sweet and
sour that you need to set off the taste
buds so the customers like the pickle
pie but I think the biggest selling
point is curiosity
this look like the D that's just pie
tastes very similar to a pumpkin pie
it's not like overpowering here anything
big flavor sweet a little sweet it's
like super sweet it's not really sweet I
think it's gonna sell Vic Niall is a
very small little town we are about
three hours from Salt Lake City then you
don't have to live in a great big city
to have good food you have to have pride
and an imagination it's more than just a
pie it's your work of art it's something
that you have done and it looks pretty
and it tastes good and you can be proud
of it
[Music]
in the united kingdom pi as a king not
just for the cherries in the apples that
you Yanks are used to you have your
chicken your steak and kidney your pork
pie and in one tiny fishing town you
have this a pie with what weight is that
fish head oh you've gotta be kidding me
trust me you're going to love it in this
tiny fishing village there's a pub and
in that pub they make stargaze a pie
it's a tradition that legend has it has
been happening here for hundreds of
years which begs the question why the
starry gazing pie is a pie which
celebrates
Tombo COTS going out and catching seven
different kinds of fish on the 23rd of
December you see according to the legend
it had been a stormy winter this meant
no boat managed to go out fish so people
were starving that's a local fisherman
tombow Cox he wasn't going to let his
people die I'm going he went out through
the game
yes that gate and braved the storm and
and caught the different kinds of fish
and brought it back he made the pie and
that brings us to today Tracy take it
away you get six different whitefish
bake that in the oven with some herbs
and some lemon zest put a layer of
grated eggs a nice mashed potato with
loads of cream in and then you put a
pastry lid put pilchards cut them and
then you put so that their heads are
coming out the pie and the tails are
coming out the pie you assemble all the
stars around the pie
on the 23rd of December and we give it
away free to thousands of people that
come to the village to celebrate tombow
[ __ ] night so to Tombo [ __ ] would a
legend cheers tom
so should we taste it no it's good
delicious
that really is quite delicious it's good
really good fish is lovely it's most
interesting it's it's much milder than I
thought mmm fish pond